guns no guns it doesn't matter you have
people that are mentally ill and they're
going to come through the cracks and
they're going to do things that people
will not even believe are possible
many of these shootings we have people
who have mental disturbances we know
that most of these people are mentally
deranged so do we need to do a better
job in mental health you bet we do
mental people are far likely to be the
victims of violence rather than the
perpetrators so the fact we tend to only
discuss mental health in a mass shooting
context is deeply misleading
we are not the only country on Earth
that has people with mental illnesses or
want to do harm to other people we are
the only advanced country on Earth that
sees these kinds of mass shootings every
few months
you